part of being a tech leader means that
you have the trust of
the people you work with and part of the
trust derives from an understanding of
the context in a way that is concrete
enough and exact enough
to build that trust and to make good
decisions
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel an in media
partnership with ctek
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i am with you tom mano r d
manager of versatile
the tom 33 years old lives in tel aviv
with his wife hilly and their
six-month-old baby boy calmed he's an 8
200 alumni and a hebrew university
graduate in philosophy politics and
economics and is self-trained as a
software engineer
an experienced tech leader combining
expertise in software data products and
people utam was until recently the head
of engineering at trellis ai and not too
long ago joined versatile as an r d
manager he volunteers for almost a
decade in the civic tech ngo the public
knowledge workshop and is an open source
project leader and board chairman among
other roles
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
today
i'm doing good excited to be here
we've we've had a
few backs and forth until we were able
to schedule this meeting so i'm very
excited that we're finally have this
opportunity yeah i've done quite a few
episodes until now and i have to tell
you a secret that some of the best
episodes are those that are the hardest
to schedule so so i have really high
hopes and expectations for this one
you're tom today you're an r d manager
within versatile you were previously a
head of engineering
at trellis and and lots of experience in
the tech world you didn't you know from
your education already i can see that
you're not the traditional you know tech
engineer and you also study philosophy
and psychology and and you're
volunteering a lot and so there's a
really a breadth of experiences that
you've you're bringing with you besides
just the engineering mindset which i
think is fascinating and i'm excited to
dive deep into that in these 20 minutes
so you tom we'll start off with the
easiest question of them all who who is
your tom who's your tamano
so easy um
so
i will introduce myself
so my name is yotaminora and i'm 33
years old i live in tel aviv
with my wife hilly and our baby boy
carmel who is a seven month
er
answering the question of who i am who
am i is something obviously i struggle
with every day and my path has been a
an attempt to give answers that resonate
with me
uh
on a daily basis uh it's definitely been
as as you've said
this path has led me to various paths
i've a i found myself in the last few
years highly engaged in tech and in tech
and engineering leadership
uh positions
but it wasn't
i think in my stars i did not come from
a background where you know i wasn't
a pc kid where you know it was very
clear that this would be where i would
end up and
through
a lot of search and trial and error i
i think i am now very happy with
the play store and
working in and acting in the world so
yeah let's talk about that
the entrance and fascination with
engineering while also having those
other experiences what does that mean to
you so what what draws you into the
engineering world and into management
positions within engineering and
and but but also keeping always keeping
in close touch with with those other
verticals that we that we talked about
i will start with the with my path to
engineering and then maybe it will tie
up to the leadership aspects of it
later on so
i am i am driven by
um a desire to be
impactful in the way i operate in the
world i want to do
i want my actions to have
some some sort of lasting effect i'm
very well aware of the limitations of
what a single person can do but i still
am looking to uh uh
when i go to sleep at the end of the day
i want to feel like i am trying to move
the needle making the world a better
place if we'll be cliche for a moment
and and i was and i looked at very
different ways to approach that
i consider that some path earlier in
life to focus on a more a public policy
and
roles and that sort of was a a
major motivation in
say studying philosophy politics and
economics and in schools wasn't the only
motivation that was definitely there and
eventually i ended up a
feeling that
using technology as a force multiplier
uh for impact at scale really resonated
with uh the way i if
i
feel it and
am enthusiastic about uh so to to
contrast
say an educator who works with the
uh
students in their particular class that
may have a very a deep impact on a very
uh narrow or small amount of people and
that's a very respectable and admirable
but i am looking for the breath and that
comes with being able to operate in
scale even though the uh
effect on each single person might be uh
much smaller and this in today's world
world one
technology is one of the main ways where
you can do that there are other ways but
definitely that and because i was i
wasn't as i said i wasn't a pc kid but i
was engaged with computers and i have
that orientation and that where my
search led me and and
that makes a lot of sense and and
you know following the search and where
you're at now and navigating through
different leadership positions
tell me a little bit about you know
leadership and engineering i think that
this is a topic that is not talked about
enough but you know in the world that
we're at today
it's crazy how many you know how many
positions are in leadership and tech
companies and and how you know the world
is moving to a place where a lot of
traditional companies are operating also
in the tech scene and have technology
embedded within them and i think that
this is a leadership concept that that
people are not yet really grasping
neither and and i'm
not grasping it at all so what what is
happening there and how do you perceive
your own leadership style within these
organizations
um that's a great question i think uh
so there are i think there are two uh
let's let's start with not with with
what doesn't work often in many in many
cases one is where
a
an engineer is good at engineering
has no orientation for leadership and is
being promoted to leadership position
because he's the best engineer they're
the best engineer and then you often
have the worst of both worlds where a
person who's good at engineering doesn't
get to do what they're good at and at
the same time they're not oriented
toward the questions of leadership and
are
serving their
teams or organizations badly and that
often ends up with the
tears and that's that's one thing and
then
on the other side of the spectrum
you have
um the problem where
leaders like technical leadership does
require
uh
you to be
very oriented toward technology because
there is an aspect of trust there and
there is an aspect of you need to be
able to um um
navigate
the engineering questions at hand it's
not just the people question or the
organization questions and you need to
be able to cut through the noise and
find the right a solution because in
many cases and i think that's a very
often the case in
especially in startups that are trying
to uh thread the needle of getting to
product market fit within their um
their
limited time frame where they have
funding and and with within the context
of uh very intense competition you
really need so you will have as a leader
you have trade-offs okay they're always
there questions about tradeoffs and then
the interesting part is when you
understand that sometimes the trade-off
is a false trade-off and that is
uh the key place where your skill as an
engineer or as an engineering leader
plays an important part because
if you're just a leader you'd say if you
put on top of an engineer organization
someone who is a very experienced
dedicated and empathetic leader but it
does not come from an engineering
context he would be able to help answer
the question of what is the correct rate
of under a given circumstance but he
will have hard time er exposing false
trade-offs and that's something that's
also very important for tech leader so
that's
where i think
so what is the jump that you know in
your mind that an engineer needs to make
in order to become to get that you know
understanding it sounds like there's a
lot of perspective involved there's the
ability to to see to think outside the
box and to view you know from a bird's
eye view you know what's happening and
what are the different trade-offs what
what does an engineer have to do in
order to try and get to that place
i think well you said you kind of said
the thing the key point which is having
an eye on the bigger picture and that's
the first
one of the main difficulties uh you see
with engineers struggling to make that
step to management it might not even be
a promotion in that sense because often
you would assign
an individual contributor that an
engineer is not in a
leadership position is often referred to
it would still be leading a project or
making it a tough decision and
grove and in in his book high output
management he refers to every knowledge
worker as a manager
and that is and i think that's a a very
uh smart insight on his behalf so
so engineering engineers are almost
always to some extent managers and you
can see how some people get that right
and some people struggle with that and
and in that place the uh uh
the untrained uh
project manager
may miss the bigger point and may
um
lock themselves in false trade-offs that
arise from
um
purest technological idea
ideals that are not pragmatic enough or
from not being able to
navigate the organizational waters and
from lacking the perspective of how what
the engineer builds
how it meets the user in the end so
there's a lot there's a lot of product
thinking here like how does what you're
trying to deliver solve an actual
problem and all those kind of
perspectives which are non
engineering perspectives need to come
into play and that's always a that's a
challenge and yeah
so if you're looking at your role today
in your previous roles as well obviously
your leading teams and part of the way
that an organization succeeds and and
becomes better is that you know you grow
people internally into leadership
positions they're the people that know
the code base the most they they know
the culture they're part of the company
and so you want them to to be the next
leaders what do you as an engineering
leader have to do
or where
before you go to sleep what do you think
about you know as your role in helping
develop these engineers within your own
organization
um
i guess that's where my background as an
educator from from youth movement
it
kind of springs into place i'm always
trying to think
uh on on the individual individual level
what would that person
how would the person grow like how does
that growth path for that particular
person whether it's
diving in to learn a new technology and
taking on a new
technical responsibility or whether it's
more about
being able to communicate their ideas or
their frustrations uh better and being
more effective
i'm always trying to ask that question
myself and then i engage with that
person where they are and and i'm very
pragmatic and i guess opportunistic in
my approach i would not necessarily uh
take that person to the to a tuesday
meeting and say hey listen you don't
communicate your anger well but i would
wait for the moment where the person
would be
receptive to uh that kind of message
and and that requires uh a very uh a
very keen eye to see when a person feels
that they're doing not as good as they
can and that's where that's the place
where they're receptive for feedback and
that would help them grow and i'm look
always look looking always on the
lookout for those kind of
moments right so it sounds like you know
where most
may you know concern themselves a lot
with how the conversation is going to go
and what are the things the way that you
will say things and the way that you're
going to give your feedback you're
actually saying well there's a whole
other dimension that is perhaps even
more important here which is
no knowing the audience and knowing when
the audience is receptive and and when
to actually go and approach them to and
because if they're not receptive it
doesn't matter what you're going to say
it's not going to go by well
yeah that's true the
timing and context is
almost as important
obviously sometimes you just need to
break it to them whether they're ready
or not and that's but that's just it's a
tool in your toolbox and what i
described is another tool on the toolbox
and you just have to keep that in mind
what do you enjoy most about your work
you wake up every day where do you draw
your
your joy and fun
yeah that's a great question um
i like to align people
i i feel that
just misalignment just arrives naturally
in every context where there are more
than uh one person and definitely when
you have
you know
80 people and
in hyper growth
so
and those miscommunications just happen
all the time and they become a
frustration and they
um
they're a block and on the road to
success and being able to
pick up on those misalignments and just
be the person who say who says here
you're talking about this but you're
thinking about it from this perspective
and you're like ignoring the point and
you're talking
past each other and being the person
who's able to do uh that like you know
talk to each other about the thing and
then thing work it's just um that's uh
it gives me a lot of joy i also enjoy
solving bugs and delivering code etc but
i also love solving the organizational
bugs so that's that's why i guess i'm
attracted to the uh
more like the leadership position
so even even you know with that with the
dilemma you know obviously now that with
managing people you know it's not that
trivial that you spend time also coding
and pushing go to the repositories in
fact some may even think of it as
not very beneficial to the organization
because your time spent with your people
and and you know leading them is
probably more impactful than the than
the algorithm or the lines of code that
you're going to contribute to the code
base
at that session how do you decide how to
navigate through that
so i think first of all what i enjoy
it
matters more on the weekends than on
weekdays
so
and i always try to keep in mind that
the decision needs to be derived from
what is
needed and what is best for the company
and often more often than not it means
uh coding less and
it does but to a certain extent because
as i said in the beginning part of being
a tech leader means that you have the
trust of
the people you work with and part of the
trust derives from an understanding of
the context in a way that is concrete
enough and exact enough
to build that trust and to make good
decisions and
in some roles it means
in some context it means uh
you know rolling up the sleeves and and
and
thing line of codes and sometimes
writing them yourself to a certain
extent but it has to be um
worth it for the organization because
the price is uh is high
because my impact should be through
other people not through the keyboard
generally speaking
take me back to middle school elementary
school you know roughly 10 years old
you know what what really
inspires you or what really fascinates
you
in your as you roam around the world
where where does your mind take you
um
so
it's going to sound it may be sound a
bit made up but i am this is completely
true i promised you i was very
fascinated since uh i
at least since first grade with social
structures i would just you know sit in
class and
and try to like to analyze
like you know who's the head boy and
who's
what does it mean to be a follower and
having like an understanding of how like
the social map works and how it uh
how it manifests in your life and you
know looking at the girls structure and
like having no clue like at all how does
that work you know later in life and now
i understand what i wasn't looking at
correctly but this is it's the sort of
questions that that were really
fascinating to me uh as a kid and so i
guess it's not
not surprising that i still enjoy doing
that part of the of
the job today
and i love it i also i also like
dinosaur you know don't get me wrong but
like
just like that i'll take the social
structure as one i i'll i take it and
i'll believe it
and and if you go today and you you know
you wake up every day and you continue
your work and
it's not easy work you have to dedicate
a lot of yourself
with with the baby as well and family
where do you draw your inspiration from
what inspires you in your day-to-day
um
so
i think i guess my these days my main
inspiration
is my baby boy
except for you know spending time with
him is uh is a pure fun and uh
and uh
i get to experience a lot of love
obviously this is talking about the
daytime but like nighttime is not as
much fun
as as in the day but more so i you know
a baby is in a growth mindset like no
adult can be
every day he learns something new
and faces his challenges head on and
that's really inspiring you know as as
an adult trying to maintain that growth
mindset it's it's crazy inspiring yeah
you know amazing
well we'll see we'll see when i
we'll see when i get to experience this
at some point but but there's there's
time so i'll take your word for it and
tell them
what are a few words that
you
your wife
your colleagues how would they describe
your
tamil um
so i don't know about them i will say
what i describe how i describe myself
and hopefully they will agree with me
and so i would describe myself as
a thoughtful
a pragmatic and
curious
thoughtful pragmatic and curious
thank you very very much this was a
really really interesting and i think it
was i loved getting the deep dive into
you know you're the way your mind works
and how you know you how you balance
being both you know a tech geek but also
a thoughtful humanitarian and
sort of an anthropologist from 10 years
old from what i gather and so you tom
thank you very very much and stay safe
and stay healthy
thank you i enjoyed it so much glad we
had a great opportunity
yes
[Music]